[Music]
in
king of pop news
what are you playing michael jackson
beat it michael jackson fight song i
already know how to play that
it's hard to play it on this one because
you have to hit the notes immediately
from this
he's a musician no i can't hear it
from over here it sounds like your
little stick is like crooked because the
notes come out all whack
submitted by i'm sorry joe yeah right
i'll [ __ ] slap the [ __ ]
for those of you that don't know joe's a
huge mj fan
he made us go to this vegan i didn't
make you go [ __ ] you guys wanted to you
know
the vegas one show
[Laughter]
but unfortunately we sat way too close
and he didn't look like michael up close
so you just couldn't even get into the
dance move
you could see the hard lines on the
makeup every time he goes on stage
michael just [ __ ] possesses this dude
and chats really was it really that
great yeah like if we were further away
i wouldn't believe that was michael so
that's the first time like being close
actually hurt the
experience yeah yep you're just like you
just saw big contour lines like this
and then the next day we did the what
what was that what kind of contour it
was
the circle yeah the sex one i forgot
it's called
but that's humanity that one exactly we
were sitting way too far we're like [ __ ]
we're shooting closer for this one
mike the michael jackson one show is
[ __ ] dope though it's amazing really
good
i've seen it a couple of times out in
the hologram and [ __ ] you should see it
yeah they're bouncing off trampolines
playing guitar no both yeah there's like
four foot chinese circus guys that come
out and [ __ ]
spin around it's dope you should see it
before it literally gets canceled
forever because i know
his whole legacy is burning down around
him no no no no no
why do they do that well because the
mainstream media is [ __ ] up that's why
but go on let's catch up some people up
to speed
because i got some [ __ ] and i got
something to say to what steve just said
but
something else we're gonna get right to
them okay the hbo documentary leaving
neverland is shocking viewers and
threatening michael jackson's estate
we should burn all of his music in a
public square
and it should not be listened to anymore
that's what i think [ __ ]
and all hats and clothing all of it
wade robinson's a [ __ ] scam
artist but go on these are the guys that
created leaving neverland [ __ ]
safe chuck you're like dangerous the
director this is wade
and then this is safe chuck james safe
chuck
they look like an edm group or something
so wade
says that he met michael jackson when he
was five years old yeah five five five
years old he won a contest
in australia to meet him and then james
met michael jackson in a pepsi
commercial
when he was 10. so here's some photo if
you told me that that was coldplay i'd
believe it
[Laughter]
no reason to argue at all oh sure could
be
more creed yeah okay james and then
michaels so they were
like really close and then so was wade
he was really close
to michael and so they created this
documentary
claiming that michael sexually abused
the both of them and did anyone see it
by the way i saw it
i did i read points about it i didn't
get to see you i watched both
two hours both two hours and in the
opera that's four hours yeah four i
watched some of that oprah [ __ ]
over four or against one i'm surprised
that oprah even covered it
i didn't know about oprah's thing
everyone's covering it right so after
the second episode or the second
uh installment oprah did uh basically
talking neverland
yeah uh wade dan and uh and james
and i don't know if she was she actually
probably asked more hard questions to
wade than the documentary ever did
yeah because on the internet everybody
was like wait you like because there's
like a whole timeline of all the times
basically wade tried to cash out
what michael jackson was like it's been
a lot so uh his memorabilia he wanted to
do the cirque du soleil i mean his whole
life was his whole career was michael
jackson yeah there's no other way he
made money
yeah yeah so actually did you know he
would choreograph for nsync
and brittany well he actually [ __ ]
britney and and
ruined the relationship between justin
timberlake and britney spears damn you
did you're a homer
he literally [ __ ] her that's what
crimea river was about
what whoa really yeah there's even like
no i mean this is prime brittany like
2001 yeah this was like uh
yeah that is prime they even did a they
even did a show like a recap
like a show about it too where like like
justin and brittany's fighting they're
like wait robin why him
he's a he's like a big dance
choreographer
in the in the industry and then so you
know how britney spears is a dancer and
all yeah yeah
he was her core creative director right
so then she cheated on
justin with him i did not know but so
he's a career
con like he's did this with uh prince's
girlfriend um it was like he [ __ ] me
prince's girlfriend too yeah he [ __ ] a
lot of girls and ruined a lot of
relationships and [ __ ] a lot of people
over
and he's a complete fame chasing ass
[ __ ] so that's one of the things
that overaxed about him
where he had a terrible like he had a
really bad answer she was like
um because essentially i didn't know
this either he
testified for michael when he was 11 and
then again when he was like 22
and like even michael died like it was
up until like maybe four or five years
ago he had been in 2012
yeah pro michael every time he had an
opportunity right he'd been pro michael
and then um after he died then he um he
had a therapist or something like that
so ober was like why did you like sue
him when you said you you were against
him and wade was like well you know
uh i was just looking for the right
platform and you know the legal system
is a platform
and i was like family that's who's his
platform like that though
i don't know that i'm using the legal
system as a plan no one in the history
ever
i would have actually believed him if he
would have just been like man i wanted
to cash out
yeah that would have made more sense
even the other guy's mom the other
the other kid that met him yeah when he
was 10 like they were interviewing the
mom and doctor this is as far as i got
in the documentary maybe like the first
minute and then she was talking about
how he was discovered and that the agent
was telling her that her son's like oh
this is money in the bank i want him and
the mom's like oh that's cool
and she was like the stage mom and me
came out oh that's the other mom
oh that's safe yeah but the safe check
mom and i'm like
what the [ __ ] you guys are all [ __ ]
scumbag so at that point i'm like i
don't need to watch the rest of this i
already know what type of people
both of these people came from yeah or
families well
but can a piece of [ __ ] get diddled i
think is the thing
yeah yes you're right they can get
diddles so so that's my thing is like
okay so and like what you're saying
right so he
was a big defender of michael and what
you're about to say he was a big
defender michael his whole life he even
testified in court that michael did
michael was awesome to him but then he
went to therapy and he discovered that
these old feelings he had for michael
there was
like a lot of troubling things that
happened like is that possible i think
that's definitely a possibility but
there's also motive tied to his
shadiness which is
him being denied for the michael jackson
one courier choreographed role
he he begged the estate of michael
jackson to become the
the main uh choreographer for the for
the show
they denied him and then that's when
things started to go down he wrote a
book about it
he wanted to it came so conveniently
after the fact that he didn't have a job
anymore with the group
so previous to that as recent as 2009
he sent an email with him and his family
and basically saying like you know
i want to go to michael's funeral if he
had all these
feelings about him it doesn't make any
sense it's so cool
you can love your molester yeah that's
true but it does it to me it's like it's
so convenient that
after he doesn't have a job anymore he
doesn't have money anymore he
conveniently goes to a therapist
and magically realizes oh he actually
did
molest well here's my thing because i
had the same thoughts
i think wade's credibility is is weak
right
he doesn't come across believable but
that doesn't mean he's lying right but
the other dude doesn't seem like an
opportunist well i don't really know
anything about safe chuck yeah safe
chuck there's no like
no job no money no legal thing and and
even like in the open thing like the
safe like wade kind of comes off as a
performer
all the time like he literally looks
like he's trying to push you know but
the other dude was like sweating and
he's just like
he looks like he's not over it at all
right and i think the thing about
michael jackson that that is hard
is like he's intertwined in our
childhood at least in mine like
i mean those music videos when scream
came out and dangerous and moonwalker i
had the game like
you don't want to believe that stuff but
for the truth is we don't really know
these people we don't
at all and michael admitted that he had
kids at the house
all the time but you know what makes me
feel a little bit less so i'm with
with the argument of like we never know
right right there's obviously
his side hurt the other person's side
and there's obviously the truth
so we will never know especially now
because i mean
michael jackson has passed but like
corey feldman who we all know
uh was a child actor he was repeatedly
sexually abused just in hollywood he was
just passed around
um he backs up michael like crazy so he
was like he's a lot of people
yeah it's fun so does uh there's also
there's also people that aren't as
famous like brett barnes yeah
so in the documentary um the two guys
get replaced by this neck but this other
boy
which is brett barnes and brett barnes
what do you mean by replaced
well so if you watch the whole thing
yes
right and then they feel replaced right
and then so uh but you don't think
that's weird
that is weird that's [ __ ] okay i'll
get to why i'll get to why it's we
like why it looks like pedophilia and
all that but it isn't but so
um um so he gets replaced by macaulay
culkin and then
and then during that time it's uh brett
barnes so brett barnes spent the most
time with michael jackson
alone in in the longest time like seven
eight years or something like that
but he on his twitter is coming out in
defense of michael saying this never
[ __ ] happened
whatever whatever and um it's
inconsistent
of a pedophile why is it that like these
guys like macaulay uh everybody that's
with him
doesn't say that this happened and every
single pedal
uh every single person that's claiming
that michael jackson is a pedophile
their [ __ ] is crumbling like it doesn't
it doesn't sam
well safe chuck isn't crumbling and i
don't want to say this
my oh my my big thing is that we were
talking about just the other day
is i found out if i'm a famous person it
looks like not just famous but i can't
go literally anywhere
uh the most exactly the most famous
person especially at that time
he could go to antarctica and get mobbed
by eskimos you know what i'm saying yeah
penguins are like
my brother i got the black and white on
because it's blue criminals
exactly yeah right they're coming over
no but okay so
if i'm michael jackson why would i
molest someone else with power and with
a voice that's what i was thinking it
doesn't make any sense it's like
macaulay cochran if you're if you're
smart
you're adding logic to it and with
pedophiles it's an urge they can't right
they can't help themselves well no but
they can select targets
but they can't help themselves going
with yours your your argument right yeah
there is a uh forensic psychologist from
the
universe uh like cincinnati university
or something like that
and he specializes in this stuff and he
did a
like ten year study on the profile of
michael jackson
and this person specializes in
pedophilia
and he says that his behavior and
personality is not consistent with a
pedophile right and if he was
he would be the first of his case in a
million years yeah
and the reason for that is they're
saying like yes pedophiles do
have things to lure children they like
to have toys they like to have
things like that and so but in michael's
case he's actually
enjoying the things that he owns so he
himself is
he has a stunted growth mentally and
emotionally he's a child
that's why he enjoys those things with
the people of the same
mental wavelength yeah so that that to
me was like okay now you have this pros
saying that
the profile and everything just doesn't
fit a pedophile's profile
on top of that the fbi investigated
michael for about 13 years
during that investigation they couldn't
find anything to indict him
and on top of that he went through a
scandal in yeah the one that put him as
a molester i think it was like
so i think that it was like jacob or it
was someone else but anyways
the big one where the whole scandal
erupted right yeah
so what happened after that um so they
settled outside of court 25 million
right they settled outside of because
they had to yeah here's the big
settling doesn't mean you're guilty yeah
right exactly but here's the thing
because it's a criminal investigation
the the this
the fbi and the county of santa clarita
or whatever they continued it
and they had a grand jury which you
you're not supposed to do what do you
mean
well if one's already happening and it's
getting settled you can't continue the
other one on another entertainment no no
the thing is like so even if it was
settled it doesn't make him off the hook
because it's a criminal act of
pedophilia so then
it's like if there are actual
molestation they have to continually
investigate it which they did and they
couldn't find
anything to indict him on and in that
area the law is
they could indict him on just hearsay so
what happened was
the person who was claiming michael was
a pedophile after they got the
settlement
he no longer cooperated with the uh
police
on top of that all the witnesses that
they crossed examined and everything all
of their
all of their i guess cases were
crumbling yeah so every single person
that's coming out
they're not withstanding and holding so
i'm i'm like
and they searched like 12 laptops all
michael what's the thing
that they were saying uh because of that
first case i think it started off
because this guy
wanted to do a movie or something with
michael michael didn't want to fund it
or something like that and he was like
well i'm going to get you for everything
that you have and then he brought in his
son
to say like yeah michael molested me or
whatever yeah and because of that whole
case i think
they put this law where that couldn't
happen anymore because of michael
jackson's case but i can't remember
exactly what it was
i thought it was funny watching parts of
the clips of it
where he's like robinson is like i
why would i do this for money i'm not
that i'm not in this for money but then
you can see that he was suing the estate
for like 1.6 billion dollars
for once in my life i would love for
someone who's in it for the money to say
i'm in for the money yeah you can people
would understand that
right you say you robbed me of my if if
true you robbed me of my ability to make
money in the future i don't know how you
justify 1.5 billion dollars but i need
to party the rest of my life because i
have so much damage
what's weird is how can you sue a dead
person
the estate but that's what i'm saying
it's weird it's like uh if he wasn't
rich and like let's say you're just
trying to really fight for justice right
yeah
if you're really just trying to fight
for justice and like let's say let's say
we have a son right the person that we
do have a son okay let's say that person
that killed our son
let's say that person dies in a normal
justice system that ends there
we don't try to go after their family or
the murderer's estate like we don't keep
going until the end like why why aren't
they
well if if we knew that they had
something even if it's like a brick and
mortar and we want vengeance we want to
hurt
that whole lineage so it's not even
about justice not from damage dude it's
about maximum damage
yeah it sucks that's what it is yeah if
i if the if someone murdered my son
and i was vengeful like that i'm like i
want to hurt everyone that has your
[ __ ] blood
your last say i want all of you guys
gone so i understand the motive and then
i'm terrified
system is supposed to be there for our
checks and balances isn't it
it is so why are they even letting
something like this like i don't
understand how you could sue a dead
person well it's like the tupac estate
like if you just started like
you know ripping off his music and that
i get if it's royalties
i get that stuff but if it's like a
direct action like tupac
sucked me in the face namasu his mom all
right it's like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah tupac doing the face
right right right right like i don't i
don't understand that point odd too it's
like he's
dead like just let the man rest i don't
know like
if if this is all true then damn that's
crazy but then like obviously
it's so up uh what is the opportunist
here
it's so convenient that after someone
dies you can't
there's no such thing as super
defamation and that's that's something i
saw that i thought was hard is like
uh wade robson had all these different
claims against other companies and
circles and he didn't mention any of
that in the documentary because they can
still suffer defamation
but michael jackson can't so people were
like well it's incredibly convenient
right not even the estate because i know
the estate is suing for 100 million like
hbo all right
still had a contract right but that's
something else because they um
they had an agreement that they if they
broadcast one of his concerts they could
never basically
post anything that had him negatively
like
showed him negative got it so that's the
the the hbo thing god
information thing i think is and that's
the thing about that
i i don't know whether it's true or not
but i think wade actually hurts this
more than
the other guy because his history of
stuff looks so
shaky it's like even if you're telling
the truth it's it's two
it's two coins it's two right right too
many times would be the queen
to be couldn't win to dinner yeah you
know what i mean and there's so many
inconsistencies in his story too
because he'll say like oh uh i i lost
complete contact with michael when i was
12 years
old but there's so much and he's like oh
michael kept me separated from women
but like there's pictures of him with
lisa marie presley and he's holding an
umbrella
for michael jackson and them hanging out
together they've been friends they've
been working together
and um if he was trying to keep him away
women
why did michael hook him up with his own
niece
yeah for seven years he was with he was
with her
it's like brandi jackson i think she
came out saying he's a scumbag he's a
[ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ] he cheated on
me he was horrible as a boyfriend
um so hard this is this let me ask you
this
do we you wanna talk about profiling for
a sec do we actually believe
that michael jackson didn't have a
wedding ceremony with a kid because i
find that
pretty believable that's the thing i saw
this tweet
you know what i'm saying in the
documentary james safe chuck said they
had like a wedding ceremony they
exchanged
all this stuff and somebody said if
michael jackson wasn't a pedophile he
was definitely wearing a pedophile's
uniform yes
and that's the thing about him like he
had so much questions it's not like a
celebrity
he's weird as [ __ ] yes who never had
like you know just say eat yourself elba
not
i don't want him you know he's never
been accused of having kids at his house
would be like you heard that he'd be
like what dude i never had no kids at my
house yeah but michael if you look at
michael's childhood and the way he was
raised in like his entire background and
his family and all that like it makes
sense why he ended up being the man and
also like
have you guys ever played house like
when you're like your first grade like
on the like in the middle of the field
right
so for me the waiting for michael's
behavior is not too weird if he did have
a wedding because
imagine playing house but now you have a
bazillion dollars yeah but imagine being
a 35 year old man
marrying an eight-year-old kid yeah but
he's so stunted
i wouldn't be surprised if he had a tea
party with him famous at like
five yeah like forever after five all
his fame did was grow
yeah and he was like super famous in the
jackson five only
and they say like whenever you become
famous like you basically stop
maturing past that age and he was like
literally five years old performing in
like strip clubs and like
lounges and stuff yeah and having grown
women throw themselves at him like
all his so and that's what wade and the
dude were saying like obviously
everybody knows that story
and and michael used that to to play you
know plays interesting like i'm a little
kid
and stuff and everybody knows that so i
mean it's it's really murky waters and
it seems very unfair
to michael that that wade had an
opportunity to do this while he was
alive or multiple
multiple his thing now is like well i
was groomed i didn't know that until i
had my own kids and then i started
really putting things together and
that's a [ __ ] up thing to say because
that is possible
it's very believable impossible you've
been groomed and now you're just like
grooming is real and you could like
repress those memories
yeah if that was me and you like you're
trying to have a career you could be
like i'm not even gonna admit that that
happened ever
like i'll lie but at the same time i get
him at 11 year old
11 years old but 22 is a little bit
harder to do it
and then his history makes the whole
thing harder yeah to believe because
it's not he's not a clear-cut
you know oh you know what i mean it just
looks like he's trying to take advantage
yeah but michael's was weird
man like he was [ __ ] weird i give you
that a million percent
not that weird he was very well
understood
is that parents are so [ __ ] hungry
for fame
yes that you do this [ __ ] like the
parents should be getting [ __ ]
they were like handing their kid
children to a to a children's services
step in so
he's innocent dude how dare you so one
of the kids that um
one of michael's accusers i think it was
jacob or someone else
was it gavin our vizio no uh it's it's
it's the one with the dentist dad or
whatever it's um
basically there's like a huge chance
that his parents
made him do this for money because
this is what this is what happened after
the lawsuit he emancipated himself from
his parents oh yes
and he refused to to [ __ ] talk on his
documentary he he refused to testify in
court in 2005.
he refused against michael police yeah
and after that
point on he just kind of excommunicated
they did mention in the documentary he
like disappeared
kind of he he couldn't live with the
guilt that's what i'm thinking
because he also got paid off he got hush
money was that the guy good he was a
minor at the time
and then people were breaking down his
parents
and saying that they were the ones that
were forcing him and that's the thing
that could be true too
people can absolutely be like hold on
this is a golden opportunity
to extort him you know what i mean like
that's the thing like all these
scenarios can make sense
dude for 1.6 billion i would tell
someone that michael jackson sucked my
dick
i would i'll do anything for 1.6 million
yeah and all you have to do is see
michael jackson suck my dick it's like
that's pretty that's pretty i think the
only the only way i will
start
think about it think about it though
when you say stuff my ears are not ready
to process it it's just like wait what
billion billion billion with a b people
right now listening are like i would
never do [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] steve's scumbag that's because
you don't even know what a million means
you don't even know what 100 000 means
right and then a million and then 10
million 100 million and a billion it
sucks how many people
[ __ ] um turned their backs and
backstabbed uh michael jackson and how
many times it has crumbled
it does okay the only reason i mean the
only way i will believe
is if macaulay culkin or brett barnes
comes out
and changes their story and says yes i
actually was but wouldn't you say that
he's a lot he's lying because he's
that's what they said about wade like
you would destroy macaulay no no no if
they actually came out about it
i would say okay i i'm gonna start what
if they were
so good that they they don't even know
that it even it doesn't make any sense
because macaulay
like people are saying like oh
macaulay's just protecting michael
because he loves him or whatever right
and he's
he doesn't want to shame him but it
doesn't make any sense because
he threw his own dad under the bus
[ __ ] his dad was
abusing him yeah yeah he did and then he
[ __ ] call the cops on him he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
so yeah well it doesn't mean that
michael jackson molested every kid he
met
like that's what grooming is right well
that's inconsistent to a pedophile like
think about
think about r kelly right almost like
there's
and and on top of that there's more
people coming out yeah
more and more people coming out
videotapes with
solid very solid stories yeah and
literal little
videotapes videotape and he's still like
me
i know that was my brother he is the
best dude
did you guys see his most recent yeah
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy he is amazing
i'm fighting for my life
he's an innocent man trying to fight for
his life [ __ ] you
i hate him no i love our killer he's
like i gotta see my kids he's like a
hundred thousand dollars behind a child
supporter he went to jail again
yes did you see his non-stop long enough
to give us that golden interview and
then he went
right back to jail i like how he was
getting makeup applied and [ __ ] and he
kept [ __ ] yelling
he couldn't stop and gail was just like
robert
robert she doesn't care she was
completely unbothered by all his antics
that made it that much because he's
sweating and punching and people are
grabbing him and she didn't even stand
up
i wish she called him our she should
have called her mark
dude that [ __ ] was trapped in a closet
real life
it just needed to be
[Music]
you